Schwarzenegger I I've read that you guys
actually hated each other for a while we
were very competitive yeah I think
Hate's a good word no I really respect
this guy I think I think he's brilliant
what he's done what he's a cop he's had
three different careers that's great but
I want to strangle him but yeah but I
mean you would do Rambo and then he
would do commando I heard that I heard
that he tricked you into doing the
movies that didn't work there was a
there's a there's a thing you know when
people pray on your insecurities when
you go your agent goes you got to do
this move you got to this movie because
Arnold's gonna do it I go really good I
don't I said oh
I don't think honor can do this one
because he's playing like an American
cop and they don't have German accents
they're just not gonna because I'm
telling you if you don't do this thing
stop on my mama shoot he's in he's in I
go uh okay I'll do it